[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello there guys my name is opal cadman
and welcome
today i have three main tasks the first
one
is to introduce you to koch media's
brand new
premium gaming label number two is to
take a deep dive into some of the games
coming to that label
and finally number three is to show you
what the new label
will be getting up to in the streaming
world
i want to welcome streamers who are
co-streaming this today
hello some of you guys are guys who i
have looked up to and watched for many
years
and speaking of people who i've looked
up to for many years
i am so proud to introduce
jeff keely who will be helping me
co-host us through this entire list of
games
jeff how's it going thanks opal it is so
great to be here with you
for the first ever live stream from
prime matter i was honored yesterday
to reveal the label to the world at the
summer game fest
uh kickoff event and wow you've got a
lot of games there
in that sizzle over a dozen games so i
know today
you're gonna go a little bit more in
depth uh to talk about all these games
talk a lot of the developers um but uh
for those of you that that might have
missed it yesterday or just want to see
it again let's kick things off
with a look at that announcement sizzle
reel for prime matter
sometimes i ask myself what what it all
means
let's begin
wow
[Music]
is that who you are my purpose
makes me who i am
i finally have the feeling we're doing
something worthwhile being relied on to
succeed
where others would fail
[Music]
so
prime matter
yes guys you just saw 12 games
and counting and that's just the start
for prime matter
but before we get into these incredible
games
what i like to call the juicy bits
i want to talk to you about what
primatter is
and who we are prime matter is the new
premium gaming label of koch media
it dedicates itself to delivering a
range
of immersive and diverse games
from amazing development talent all
around the globe
it highlights the varied influences of
global studios
and their different approaches to game
making the new label will lead through
creativity
and expression with games that enthrall
players
with larger than life storytelling
create incredible moments
and above all they're fun the team
behind prime matter
is a melting pot of incredible talent
led by
seasoned industry veterans and
complimented by a young
fresh dynamic team of multicultured
gaming
experts the team behind are gamers at
heart
working with such a wide range of
passionate developers producing games
together
by gamers for gamers
and that being said for all you keen
eyed individuals out there you would
have seen that one game was actually
missing
in our 12 game lineup for prime matter
during the video
that is a game that comes from the
embracer family
itself jeff got to sit down with todd
holland's head
and talk all about painkiller
all right you saw the news yesterday yes
there is a new painkiller coming and
todd is joining me now to maybe give us
a few more details i know
uh this is kind of a fresh project for
the team at sabre and you guys uh
first of all i love that you and tim
willetts are there
um continuing to to build out saber uh
and painkiller
was a franchise you you and i are both
og
uh we remember uh it was was it probably
15 years ago at this point
yeah it's been a while uh you know
closer to two decades than one
my god all right well but it's one of
those classic games uh
let me ask you from a prime matter
perspective you know you've been in the
industry like me all those years and we
remember that game why was this a
franchise that you guys wanted to sort
of
bring back well you know
um painkiller when i played it back in
the early 2000s this was a game that had
you know
it was dark a little twisted intense
cool guns
these are the things that you know kind
of hit the nail on the head of what
appeals to me in a in a video game
both as you know as a fan and then also
as a publisher at saber so
you know we hope we're hoping to capture
those same sort of elements and bring
those into the new game
yeah uh you know you guys are certainly
masters of doing uh shooters from uh
all your time at id and uh painkiller
you know it does have a lot of that dna
of
you know fast-paced action with a little
bit of a twist to it
uh and you know the fact you guys are
working with prime matter is also
exciting uh
you know brand new publisher brand new
label um
what do you think of the fact that
they're doing this label and you know
it's such a diverse lineup of of
companies and partners around it
um you know i know you guys work with a
lot of publishers but it's pretty
exciting
to uh to see a new label announced that
doesn't happen every day
no it doesn't and uh you know i think
that uh
within the embracer group you know it's
just a it's just a business that is
growing
uh we've got great leadership at the top
and so coke media is
you know wanting to expand their
publishing and i think that you know the
name they chose prime matter sort of is
you know sort of like the primordial
soup of putting together stuff from
nothing so
you know it kind of makes me think of
this is what we do when we make video
games you know you sort of start with
pixel 0 and then at the end of the day
you make a game so i feel like that
you know that kind of resonates with
hopefully the the type of experiences
that we're going to be providing
you know not just within prime matter
and working with them
between saber and our partnership but
you know across the
across the embracer group as well yeah
no it sounds like they have a lot of
games and development but the fact that
you are bringing
back painkiller is really exciting and i
know you know
fans of course want to know a little bit
about you know
what's the game going to look what's
going to how is it going to play
um probably can't share a lot of details
about it but you're kind of in the early
stages of development now on this
yeah super early and uh you know if i
anything that i would share i'd probably
get uh
assassinated four back home once i got
back to the developer because you know
all these you know the the the first
stuff that comes out almost always gets
sort of
iterated on and changed and so we're
trying to keep uh
trying to keep the lid on the details
until we we have something that's
gonna be really awesome to show all
right well we'll be waiting for it and
we know with with you involved
uh it's gonna be something very special
uh
fast-paced action i have no doubt so new
painkiller
coming soon from the team at uh sabre
published by prime matter thanks todd
thanks jeff
i really can't wait to hear more about
painkiller and the fact that todd and
tim and the team at sabre are working on
it
i think we're going to get something
pretty special when they are ready to
share
more so you know exciting stuff in that
sizzle reel
painkiller payday but i know there's a
lot more we're here to talk about today
as well right opal
actually prime matter has 12 games under
development
right at this minute we're so excited to
show you guys what us
and the developers have been up to
however before you see
some of the content that we show you
today i do have to make it clear
that some of this is pre-alpha alpha
high level concept and some of it is
about to release right around the corner
so please keep that in mind when you're
viewing today's show
that being said how do you guys feel
about a psychedelic
third person survival horror game
set on what it means to go on a journey
about self-enlightenment
and what happens when it all goes wrong
i got to speak with the developers of
the chant work in progress title
about their game and who they are
our game is about uh a group of people
who go to a
spiritual retreat to uh seek
enlightenment
and uh they basically get a little more
than they bargained for
and um your character has to deal with
um her own personal issues as well as
the uh
cosmic terrors that uh become awakened
cool so um
what type of genre is this game and it's
a bit hard to pin down with the
um with uh with all the different
influences and
styles of gameplay but i'd say we're
we're probably a survival action horror
game
okay cool cool and what was the like
what was the thinking behind that genre
is it something that you guys like
or did is it just it came left field
what what's your decision behind that
um uh personally we always uh
wanted to make a horror game um our are
a big part of our core team
have a have a background in uh third
person sandbox games
and um we really wanted to combine you
know action mechanics
uh deep storytelling and uh we felt that
you know the horror genre was a was a
really exciting uh
space to uh to take that uh that
background and play around with
so kind of sticking with the horror
genre
why did you decide to go with that theme
it's not really like
normally what you would see um this
whole spiritual awakening thing so what
was the what was the idea behind that
uh we thought it was just kind of a an
interesting um
territory to explore uh uh there is
um you know there's a lot of influence
um
from that with like folk horror of the
70s and and
and jalo horror and so forth that um
really really inspired us
more from a film standpoint and you know
taking that kind of aesthetic
uh something that was very sensational
very colorful
and um mixing it in with um with
uh you know kind of uh more
action-oriented and exploratory game
mechanics
we felt was it was was was a fresh take
on the horror space
so kind of speaking about your
inspirations and stuff
what video games real life media has
inspired you to create this title
uh well going going way back when uh
resident evil
resident evil 2 is one of my favorite
games of all time
alone in the dark uh eternal darkness
so a lot of a lot of games are very
inspirational to us our game actually
started off as a
as a game with fixed camera angles and
so forth and then we um over the course
of
over the court yeah over the course of
development um just especially really
focusing on uh
on on bringing more of an action element
to it we um
we've since switched to an
over-the-shoulder camera and haven't
looked back
so kind of talking about changes and and
what you guys
are doing on the development side how
close is the game to like the original
concept i understand you guys are still
development
uh developing the games quite far out
but from your original concept to where
the game is now how much has that
differed
uh the core story and i'd say the
aesthetic
and the themes those are all um those
all remain intact i'd say our gameplay
um as our team size grew
uh we we added um we added more uh
we added deeper mechanics i'd say more
action to the game our game actually has
a fair amount of combat
in it especially on the melee side
those were things that weren't too
prevalent in our original concept and
a lot of a lot of those things are just
kind of uh based on
um you know we we're we're very small
team at first
we're still a relatively small team but
um every new person that joins you know
brings
brings something new to the mix so i'd
say on that end uh
the game is the game has evolved in in
you know scope
and depth of gameplay awesome kind of
sticking on that point of you know
you've got a small team there's a lot of
challenges that comes with that
what was the hardest part of making the
game so far
uh the hardest part it was probably
trying to make a game that
um you know has you know more realistic
production values because that's where
our our background comes from um
on a on a smaller scale and budget so um
for us we had to be very strategic um
utilizing unreal
uh we wouldn't be able to build this
game without you utilizing an engine
like unreal previously we had worked on
more proprietary technology
and that's also great because you know
new people that join the team can
can get up and running on the engine
quite quickly
in addition to that we've been using
photogrammetry from the start
um for both our environments
all of our characters are also scanned
actors
and we're using uh you know also tapping
into a lot of what's going on
in our city uh vancouver has a pretty
big film industry so
really tapping into the film and the
effects industry and
and tapping into that area of expertise
to just kind of
try to do things um as efficiently as
possible so you've mentioned like
experience in the past and also kind of
how rich
vancouver is how much does that come in
handy when you're working on the game
well it's been a extremely beneficial um
vancouver you know is home to a lot of
triple a studios
a large portion of us work together at
rockstar and united front games
and we also have people who have
worked at the coalition and ea
as well as some some smaller independent
studios as well
and in addition to that um you know
having having the film industry here
where we can
we can um utilize you know local
talent uh we're working with union
actors we're scanning um
we're scanning actors as well they're
using for our characters and
we're actually currently auditioning um
a couple remaining characters for the
game
and um as well as uh doing the finishing
touches on our
new motion capture studio so we're going
to be um
doing a full um cinematics push
over the coming months that's uh that's
a really exciting
[Music]
place to be right now awesome sounds
great in terms of
exciting things when it comes to this
game
what are you most proud of at the minute
where you are i think the
the thing i'm the most proud of is is
just what a what a small
focused team can do when they're all you
know sharing the the same goal and
vision
you know we like as i said earlier we
you know we come from
um different backgrounds but everyone's
managed to come together and and and
really
um deliver uh an amazing amount of work
for um
for the team size we have and um yeah
it's just it's it's really exciting to
be working on a
on a smaller team again and um you know
just having that kind of energy where
you know you're working with everyone on
the team day to day yeah
i imagine that is a lot different to
probably what some of you used to coming
from those massive
uh studios so finally
what are the benefits of signing up with
a global publisher like koch
and also you know being featured on
their brand new label
uh it's it's truly an exciting uh place
to be we've been
kind of pushing our game as as far as we
could
and um this partnership is really
helping to
provide more reach and
more resources but i think most
importantly also just having a
partnership
on getting feedback and helping to
really expand and push the
push the vision of the game we've
already received a lot of feedback on
the title
and being a small team we're we're often
in our own little echo chamber
and um you know even in a short period
of time we've been able to act on a lot
of the feedback and
the game has improved considerably since
then
well mike thank you so much for your
time it's been awesome to talk to you
and find out a little bit more
about what you guys are going to be
offering for the new label
and i can't wait to let gamers finally
get their hands
on the content so thank you for your
time
from psychedelic horrors to internet
rumors our next developer created the
huge open world of bohemia
and took us on an adventure through the
holy roman empire
however there have been some leaks that
this action rpg may have a home on the
switch
opel sat down with war horse studios to
try and get to the bottom of this
kingdom come deliverance on the switch
that is
quite some news yes that's true kingdom
come deliverance is coming
to the nintendo switch and as you said
it's about gamers
devs and games in our case or in this
case
actually gamers play an integral part in
the story what do you mean
well some kind of confusion happened in
the
end of last year we we wahha studios
were
preparing the release of the kingdom
come deliverance royal edition on
playstation and xbox
but someone most likely ticked the wrong
box in japan and it looked like
it's going to be released on switch as
well of course
by that time there was nothing existing
like that we were not even thinking
about the possibility
that kingdom come deliverance could go
on the switch however nintendo
japan took this information some
japanese media and then the snowball
started rolling all of a sudden it was
the talk of the day kingdom come
deliverance is releasing on the switch
but as i said uh nothing like that was
planned at all and
uh we didn't even think about that now
a few months back and we think it's it
was still
somehow cursing around in the nintendo
database nintendo of spain
posted a picture on twitter where they
had
different pictures of open world games
and they were promoting
already existing open world games on the
nintendo store
and if you clicked on the picture
actually you couldn't there was nothing
like kingdom come deliverance of course
not because
as i said nothing like that is existing
however again it created confusion
people were
talking about it again like okay so is
it coming is it not coming
but for us actually and as i said we
didn't think about that until that time
for us we started to think we started to
think there's a lot of
interest there's a lot of buzz people
are actually talking about us
reaching out to us like they seem to
want kingdom come deliverance on the
nintendo switch
so we started to think and since we are
already
in the chmedia family or the embracer
family and there's a lot of talented
studios
so is saber interactive and who but then
would be
actually capable of bringing the kingdom
come deliverance version on the switch
so we sat together and now we are here
talking about the nintendo switch
version on kingdom come
so what you're saying is that a
community of gamers
made this happen more or less yes the
community feedback we got of course was
a big drive for this entire project
but this comes from our general
background so
think of the kickstarter project we had
in the day so without the community
there wouldn't be any warhaw studios or
any kingdom come deliverance so we
always try to be very close to them and
working together with them and even
coming up with crazy ideas together with
them so
uh for instance the xavier schnapps our
own liquor
we created later came was actually a
community idea
we have our own beer brand we recently
released
a blue brick set like a building set for
kingdom come deliverance buildings
and now one of the latest projects is
the
kingdom come deliverance soap bar which
should give you the real medieval smell
in that case i must say it actually
medieval smells actually pretty well
and we are coming up with crazy stuff
like that
all the time our next new merchandise
product is
or project is a farkle boxed
board game kind of so far for those who
don't know that's like a
this kingdom come deliverance mini game
the dice mini game
you can play in the game and now with
griffon studios we are coming up with a
boxed version you can get and play
farkle
at home against your friend against your
friends or against your family or
whatever
so that's that's pretty cool if you ask
me
but generally if you're interested in
these kind of stuff just check the wahoo
studios social media accounts you get
all the information you need there ooh
my favorite
soapy hot news
speaking of soapy hot news how do you
feel
about warhorse being under the new label
prime matter
it's a huge honor of course we were
working together with [ __ ] for over four
years already
in 2019 we then even became part of the
anti-embracer family so
that was a big thing and now being able
to be
to take part at the beginning of
something new be there
when there's a new label being created
that is that is a big thing for us
and especially if you consider that we
come there as an established partner
already that is really cool and we are
looking forward to
a bright future thank you very much toby
we cannot see what war horse has got
cooking however until that time toby
goodbye so are we thank you very much
and
see you from internet rumors back to
reality we will have more on kingdom
come deliverance for switch
as we get it all right let's move from
rpgs to
fps games final form which is a working
title
is an action-packed sci-fi adventure
where you play the role of a humanoid
avatar of a sentient spaceship
sent on a mission to the edge of the
known universe to battle an unstoppable
plague
the game is still a long ways from
completion but here's a very quick peek
at what's in store
[Music]
[Music]
so
hi we are recon games and what you have
just seen is the first glimpse of our
upcoming game called name final form
final form is an action-packed epic
sci-fi
fps in which you are a female formed
humanoid machine
on a space mission with no return
at the heart of the game is a mystery
and alienwares to explore but also an
adrenaline-fueled combat
in final form it's all about the freedom
and power of movement
being a machine and restrained by human
weaknesses
there are numerous abilities and gadgets
that come with your robotic body so you
can give yourself away to the fantasy
of becoming an unstoppable cybernetic
goddess blazing away in a spectacular
ballad of destruction
raikkonen is located in warsaw poland
with additional team members located
all over the world the studio was
founded and is managed
entirely by game developers
since the success of ruiner we've grown
quite substantially
currently raikkonen is over 50 brilliant
game creators
and counting we are not a huge team
but what we love to do is to evolve
together with our projects
constantly finding smarter and better
ways
to achieve something truly unique
we build our work environment just like
we make games
aiming for the best results and personal
fulfillment
we strongly believe that the well-being
of team members needs to be taken care
of first
before we can pour all of that love into
a game
[Music]
the partnership with kosh media has been
very fruitful
and inspiring we're happy to be in the
avant-garde of the upcoming new label
we're looking forward to share more on
final form in the future
and in the meantime please enjoy the
rest of the show
and see you around
i have to say guys i love the soundtrack
from vinyl form
moving on to our next game which is just
as special what if you took
lovecraftian and gagarin's themes and
mixed it all together
with hardcore rpg elements that's
exactly what massive work
studios are doing i got to sit down with
their cto to talk about their game
[Music]
[Music]
dolmen
[Music]
let's speak now to gabrielle fejera cto
of massive work studios
who joins us now from campinas near san
paolo in the southeast of brazil
sir gabrielle what is dorman about
first of all it's a pleasure to uh to be
here
and to participate well so let me tell a
little bit about what dolmen is
domain is that kind of a game that
where the hero needs to save everyone
from from an alien trap
fighting with all kinds of monsters and
struggling to keep going forward
yeah that's the kind of kind of game
that dolman is
not about in this game you actually save
the drillers which is the
alien species that live on the planet
but you're going there to
help a company save its investment so
you're not really the the nice guy
that's trying to save everyone it's just
a job
but we hope that the players
consider the humanity they created the
war
and the spurs and the challenges that
come to mind uh
along with that job uh
took in all that part and yes doma is
also about
fighting all kinds of monsters and and
struggling
after all uh it is a hard game
it's a hardcore game it's uh
inspired on souls like so yes you're
going to die a lot
awesome thank you so when thinking about
the name
dolmen obviously you guys went that for
went for that for like a very specific
reason
what's the thinking behind the name why
did you go for dorman
so uh there was many things that came to
our mind when
describing the name of the game uh domen
which means
a single chamber uh tone
a megalithic tone uh we thought it would
be a good word to describe
this stone uh this crystal that we have
that is related to that
in many ways uh everyone's that deals
with this crystal in the game
is close to being bringing problems to
everyone that is around
and we wanted this to be the main piece
of the game
cool awesome and now i know that people
may or may not have heard of dolmen
before so
um it is already out there in the world
but how long has it taken
to get to this point oh it's been a long
journey
since the beginning of the project we
started
at late 2016
so it's been almost five years now
and probably uh just a
bit more to come out uh but we
and about our journey uh if it wasn't
the sport that we had
since the beginning uh either our
community
the kickstarters and you guys
i believe would not be here right now
lovely um how have you been inspired by
other games you mentioned like the souls
like obviously inspires it
you know are there other games that
inspire you and also
what games do the teams like first of
all regarding inspirations
uh a lot of games came to came to us
when we were producing the game and when
we were first thinking of
it obviously we are really passionate
and we really love
souls like games so world born
dark souls uh those games were our
main inspirations but we drew
uh we drew inspirations from all
different kind of sources
so we had inspirations in dead space and
matter of fact
uh and also not only inspirations in
game
in other games but also inspirations in
movies and lovecraftian stories uh
for example alien and geiger and those
were our main inspirations
about games that we most like and games
that our team
likes it's really hard to say because
we have a team that ranges from
uh likings uh dota to cs and souls light
games
but what i can really tell you is that
every one of our team is passionate
about the project
because they love doing what they do
which is a hardcore game
yeah and that makes sense as well when
you get hands on dolmen
all these inspirations that have come in
so the game is set in a sci-fi
universe is there any specific reason
you just decided to go down that route
was there any other routes that you
considered at first
yeah yeah uh well
the humans are afraid of what they don't
know
and the universe has infinite
possibilities
there is always something unknown that
we can explore in space
uh so that sci-fi setting
really uh was uh
something that we could use to
throw everything that our insane minds
could come with so we wanted to use the
sci-fi
as a touch with this go to present the
player
uh a world of unknown that he can fear
and he can enjoy it no absolutely
and um while we're kind of
on the on the point of humans and earth
um you guys are based in brazil which is
awesome uh are there any specific
challenges that you face
during development because of that or
just in general
yeah but there were a lot of challenges
that we faced uh
along with this five-year journey uh
we obviously had to adapt our workflow
in this
latest years in the late years uh so to
2020 and 2020 was 21 uh
was a really challenge for us but it was
something that we could adapt
well especially because even that we
were based in brazil we're not
only based in a single location in
brazil we have people
uh spread across the country so
it was easy enough to
to overcome that challenge but
there were several challenges since
getting development kids and fighting
finding people that
are really capable of helping us to
deliver
this amazing game and that's what we uh
we gathered and that's something that
our company
uh appreciates the most and really gives
value
is the people that we work with uh they
were really it's incredible people
and they were really rare over here
absolutely that's
that's really cool um kind of on that
theme of development and challenges um
given how development and technology
often dictates how a game evolves
throughout its development
how kind of close are you to the
original concept that you guys came up
for
for dolman well uh there are different
point of views on
that answer especially because we
started
uh really small and the journey of the
game for example
it started as a concept from uh a few
friends that get together and
they bring storm in it for months
the game uh subverted in two senses
and one of them when we first thought of
the game
the game was is huge and is insane and
has
a lot of background on it it
it has all this universe around it
so a lot of it has been built so people
that loves lore
and loves uh the universe that we are
creating
they will have a lot of tricks for on
that side
but the game and from its original
concept
evolved a lot especially uh now that we
have more to use
our disposal so on the the tax side
uh intervention way better than we
imagined
back 2016 we didn't have all the
resources that we have now
so of course we made some sacrifices
here there and in order to
achieve our goal but
we're never happy uh
with uh satisfied that point of sex
passion you know
we want to reach more at the end of the
day
this is also a game and we are having
fun but
on top of all we want to make a
brilliant game for for the player
absolutely
and speaking about like making the game
and the development of the game
um seeing as you are lead programmer as
well what was the hardest part of making
the actual game
i believe that uh we could have
gone into uh different uh
options uh especially for example we
could have
wanted to make a game that was simpler
or smaller or not have that many hours
of gameplay
uh but we decided to go to
a hard car game even that's a first game
of our company so we decided to go
full into that challenge we faced a lot
of challenges
as as i mentioned previously but
i believe the hardest part of the game
was finding the correct uh
professionals and
focusing on on what we were doing and
you know keeping yourself focused for
five years on
a a single game is something that is
challenging for
everyone especially right now uh
so it was a a difficult decision but
we wanted to make that uh
yeah regarding programming and as a
as a programmer there's a lot of
that i could talk keep talking and
talking about
what is the harder multiplayer is always
challenging but
finding that that balancing fit
uh saw the game that it is not unfair
but is it is hard
so we wanted schwein hardcore players so
this
was really something that that was hard
so you mentioned
like five years of development which is
a crazy long
time how how have you kept yourself
motivated how have the team
kept themselves motivated i won't say it
was easy
uh because it wasn't but i i would say
that
most of all we were always having this
at this meetings in order to play the
game even now that we are remote we keep
uh getting up uh every day
and making a meeting and showcasing what
we are doing and working alongside
each one of us uh also
a lot of things that happened during
before before kofi
uh was the events the events always made
us super happy
so showcasing the game to everyone and
getting the players to play the game
and see how they react it was something
incredible for us
it really made us feel proud of what we
were doing
yeah absolutely i feel like everyone's
missing that event feeling right when
you actually get to see people on the
games and you're like
oh wow everyone's loving our games i
think it's something that everyone is
is missing definitely speaking of kind
of motivation and
happy times what are you most proud of
of this game what have you guys worked
on that you're like
yeah we did that i believe that the
universe
the universe that we created is amazing
it has a lot of background
from it so for example uh we even made
uh some comics for it uh that that we
prepared
uh we had a lot we have a lot of story
uh
some crazy assimilate cinematics so
really proud of the universe that we
created and
this game that we made and
achieving what we did is what make us
feel proud
and now that we have partnered with you
uh
getting to expand that universe
and getting to uh get closer to our
original concept and what we meant for
it
uh that is something that makes us
really happy
cool awesome speaking of partnership
with us what are the benefits of signing
up with a global publisher
like koch on their brand new label uh
that that's really uh that's that's
really a
amazing feeling for us uh koch really
helped us and
takes care of the of the operation that
we couldn't make it make it for
ourselves
uh they have an amazing team of qa
localization so we can reach
different countries and players
everywhere
we have a great producer that worked
with us
helping us reaching reach our goals and
really delivered game that we want
and we thought koch got opened the doors
for us
on that sense and being part of this new
label
is a great opportunity for for us uh
and also to you know other game
developers and expand
the game community and yeah and to meet
you
as well and we will really uh
thank you for this opportunity
absolutely we are
so happy to have you guys on board and
and more importantly
i am so excited to actually let people
play this game at some point under this
new label so thank you so much for your
time gabrielle
it's been awesome talking to you and
yeah
let's um release dolmen at some point
under the new label thank you for your
time and see you later
thank you see ya
now the first title from prime matter
will be the beautiful
highly anticipated kings bounty 2. we
have a first look at the gameplay
trailer
and then opal got a chance to sit down
and talk with ceo
nikolai
the balance is off
[Music]
our land nostria dances on the knife's
edge of fate
king claudius my father cannot lead
and his absence has set the realm in
motion
something is coming now the burden of
the crown
falls onto me
nostril was flourishing
but there is unrest it used to be
beautiful here my wife and i had a nice
life then
conspiracy sabotage
necromancy they all threaten
this land asunder but we must unite
for distorted terrors are advancing
rumors tell of a false prophet putting
our hope
in something that does not exist a seer
foretells that our savior
[Music]
is among us people of nostria
you laid faith in my father do so to me
we must look towards the horizon fight
back
the darkness and preserve
the light of our land
for austria
hello there guys thanks for joining me
and i
am joined by nikolai barinskoff
from 1c entertainment who is ceo
and creator of king's bounty 2. so
king's bounty has been years in
development and has a 30-year
pedigree so what is it that makes king's
bounty 2
so special the original king's bounty uh
uh
was a grandfather of games like of
series like
heroes of might and magic so it created
these turn-based gameplay when we have a
uh hex based battlefield and the troops
are moving in turns
uh you know
like chess chess pieces on the board so
i think that's that's
uh the key uh the cornerstone
of king's bounds absolutely and kind of
speaking about that and
um i know the as you mentioned the first
kings bounties was 1990
and then you had your like the king's
bounty that you guys created in
the 2000s what technical improvements
now that were in 2021
are you most excited about implementing
into the new king's bounty 2.
well i'm a huge fan of the core
aspect of the game with tactical battles
and
if in the previous games
the battlefield was always a flat
surface so now we are bringing the
battlefield into 3d
so we will have you know line of sights
uh you know
heels uh you know like simple example
if if your archers are located on the
hill they will do like extra damage for
the high ground etcetera so
moving the battlefield to 3d 3d is is a
huge
uh step forward and then the whole um
evolving part
exploration part we decided to move more
towards
games like uh you know fable or mass
effect you know epic
big role playing games as opposed to
have a
top-down isometric view with your tiny
little character on the course
just gulping around the map so we are
moving towards this kind of epic
uh fantasy adventure uh because this is
this is not
like a small indie title anymore this is
one of one of the biggest
of the biggest production uh we've done
in moscow uh
so far so speaking of the other king's
bounty games
will this king's bounty 2 follow the
other stories of the games or will it be
a standalone title
um no the game will not follow on any
previous games
but uh even the previous king's
boundaries they all sort of like
disconnected
there was like the name protagonist
they're a bunch of like you know evil
guys there's like a
um uh small quest and i would say that's
a previous king's bounty it was not like
an epic rpg adventure uh
so the game was more about just battling
uh random monsters on the map
uh and uh solving some little
quests and then king's bounty two is
really
you know a epic adventure uh we spend
like dozens of hours of
puzzles working with different functions
making decisions that change the
character and the world
so we're really moving much more uh
towards uh
you know an epic rpg however uh this is
a very combination
uh where our gameplay is bound to it's
not an action rpg it's not a witcher
game where you have to you know put to
press buttons on your joysticks and
battle
uh enemies in the field it's interesting
crossbreed of a high fantasy
role-playing game with a tactical
strategy
title which uh you know i wouldn't it's
not like quote unquote was never done
console but this is fairly unique
combination uh for the console and uh
for me like a great inspiration was uh
was the modern remake of
uh xcom for example uh because i was a
huge fan of xcom
that was released in 1994 1996 and the
modern console
uh reinventing of xcom
this is something we're trying to
achieve with king's bounty really make a
modern game that works well on modern
platforms that
works well with current understanding of
gamers how a game should look like
so yeah we're trying to enhance it in
every possible direction yeah cool
awesome kind of speaking about the story
of king's bounty 2 and how it differs
it appears to have a darker more gritty
aesthetic compared to its predecessors
what was the design philosophy around
that why did you decide to go with that
instead
that's a interesting question we've been
debating uh
on a design approach
and again as i said we spend a lot of
time prototyping
working on the core gameplay and the
looks and the art of the game
uh previous game had this more
cartoonish
kind of fancy indie look but we decided
that we are now trying to
play in different league we're trying to
make a you know much bigger title a big
game an epic adventure
uh we've been um you know astonished by
you know modern fantasy titles both in
hollywood and um in games and we thought
this is a good idea actually to upgrade
king's bounty to what we call like high
fantasy or like realistic feminism so
it's not a dark fantasy
like kingdom come when they're like you
know very peasants everything is bad
no it's more like like high fantasy uh
you know epic characters if this is
dragon it looks like a dragon not like a
toy
it is a billion you know he or she looks
like a real
bad person so that that was the main
philosophy
plus you know game development evolves
and i don't think that it's a good idea
to you know take a game of 2008
and just make a replica with slightly
enhanced graphics in uh 2021.
you need especially for consoles there's
a specific um
expectation from somebody uh coming to
the store or buying the game digitally
or online okay this is like a
49.59 game uh it has to look
graphically and gameplay-wise like this
there's an expectation and we believe
that that's
that's all we have to do yeah so we've
mentioned that this game
combines different kind of play placed
like ways that you can play the game
basically you know from third person
rpg elements to this unite unique
fighting system this kind of chess-like
fighting system
um kind of why did you choose
you know with the evolution of game
design and how people play games why did
you choose to stick
to these hybrid game mechanics do you
think that this is kind of
what makes king's bounty kings bounty uh
absolutely
i think you've got it's photos i don't
even need to answer
he's bouncy he's he's he's again
grandfather of two
you know turn-based uh games so if you
remove tactical commerce from king's
bounty then
it becomes i don't know mass effect the
kingdom comes so this is
so we can we can play around with the
evolution of this make it uh more fun or
realistic
but obviously this this is the core so
this is
this is a tactical game with a lot of
role-playing
aspects of high-fantasy aspects not the
other way
around so uh again
gamers who like uh rpg people shooting
elements uh you know games like
cyberpunk this thing's about
probably not for them i'm sorry just
it's a different game yeah and in terms
of you know we've mentioned
kind of this new 3d world that you're
creating when it comes to the fighting
style
and then this these rpg mechanics and
making this world
feel more alive and more exciting
what was actually the hardest part of
you making the game what took the
longest time what
kind of caused you the most headaches
hard to say
first of all this multiple platform game
so there are specific tactical issues uh
that
uh prolong the development if you make
just let's say pc title or just a
playstation game then
you know you are not having a headache
of uh porting to
different platforms uh getting different
uh
you know specifications tcr's approvals
so that's that that's
uh hello and then secondly the
production itself as
as soon as we went away from this kind
of cartoonish
uh kind of uh you know uh easy looking
uh isometric view into
a 3d high fantasy and the production of
ss so we
wanted to build like a huge map we
wanted to populate this map with a lot
of
characters that would just move around
uh go
uh somewhere you know have their own
like stories then we
decided to uh instead of having like
text dialogues we decided to produce a
lot of
uh engine based cutscenes to push the
story to
explain what's going on uh so we even
had to
uh buy our motion capture studio we
you know we'll work with like a dozen
actors and uh
their hours and hours and hours of uh
you know in-game based cutscenes
which in the past could be just uh
dialogues and pieces of text
that that was another uh huge
complication
no absolutely and then the final
question what are the benefits of
signing up with a global publisher like
koch and being on their brand new
gaming label oh that that provides us
a lot of additional support
because um you know i'm not sure that
all gamers understand how games uh get
to the market so making
uh making game you know writing pieces
of code or you know drawing this
you know amazing sketch of a dragon uh
is only
you know half of the puzzles it's like
you know in yang
uh you need a lot of uh support from
production people and you know
testing uh localization uh
uh manufacturing uh retail units so you
know putting all this you know
guinness into the retail shops in the
world
uh making a mess market communications
so we decided to cooperate
with coach media uh that seemed to be
the ideal partner so
i you know went on the market for many
many years and
uh i would say very honestly i was
personally
scared if we do it just ourselves that
we might not have
uh the human resources uh to deliver
uh the information about the game the
game itself you know we'll work with all
the
platform holders as effectively as in
a co-production and co-publishing uh uh
with
such esteemed uh partners you know you
know which media embraces groups
yeah awesome well that's it thank you so
much for your time nikolai
and i cannot wait for people to get
their hands on kings around e2 well me
too
trust me after two years of development
that doesn't be one of the
exciting the most exciting days for me
in 2021
we have 12 titles
we keep saying it and honestly i
shouldn't have a favorite
it's like picking between a favorite
child however
this next title speaks to me on a gaming
level
unlike any other this third person
action adventure shooter will keep you
up at night tossing and turning with its
horrific nightmarish creatures
think alice in wonderland meets alien
or as one u.s journalist put it tomb
standing guys sit back
relax grab a pillow
because you get a world exclusive look
at scars above good job dr ward
dr yashida get to the bridge please time
to see what's inside our alien guest
telemetry check telemetry check
here go
wow how is this possible
what planet is this how did i end up
here
log entry the gate has an internal
conduction system
the three points on the rim seem
sensitive a targeted blast of
electricity should cause a reaction
the debris it's from hermes it must have
splintered off as it entered the
atmosphere
mira it's still intact
uh
log entry the creature has multiple
salivary glands in its thoracic region
that seem to produce a highly venomous
secretion
wow
[Music]
the whole place is covered with some
kind of
organic residue
[Music]
looks like robinson managed to connect
the mpu to the pillar
[Music]
this will help me get through that
tissue webbing and i'm taking the mpu
so
who are the architects of this place did
they build these
towering monuments to serve a purpose or
as a testament to their might
were they looking for answers or solving
a problem
oh my god
oh
huh
this thing was huge
we're hmm
the appendages are dripping with the
fluid that's freezing
water
there's the brain the neural pathways
leading to various organs
the deutocerebrum seems to be generating
an electrical charge
this neural pathway is conducting large
amounts of bioelectricity
[Music]
this gland is secreting the cryogenic
fluid that's freezing water
[Music]
the cocktail of digestive essence is
dissolving local plant life into
homogenous matter
the process seems to be aided by
bioelectricity
[Applause]
oh
that really was something and last week
opel had a chance to talk to the
developers
mad head games and ask them what their
game was all about
hello there guys joining me now from
novi sad
in serbia is ivan zorkich game director
at madhead games
who's going to tell us all about his new
project
so ivan what's skies above all about
hey there uh so scars above
well uh you know an alien object appears
near earth
and a team of astronauts is you know
sent to explore it to do a
close range scan however uh
for some reason that i don't want to go
into now uh
this results in in them like a in an
event
which which causes them to be
transported to an unknown alien planet
so uh our protagonist kate ward who is a
mission specialist she's an
astrobiologist with a background in
engineering she's she's one of the
one of the members of the team of
astronauts of the team called
scar team which is uh sentient contact
assessment and response so she is on the
ship
doing the scan and she ends up on this
stranded on this on this alien planet
so one moment she's with her team and in
the ship and
the other moment she's on this strange
planet alone
so she explores she she she uh
finds out that that her team is also
stranded on the planet she has to find
them first
uh and it seems that some time has
passed you know she
you know she doesn't understand why and
also the planet is very hostile so
there's a bunch of dangerous creatures
uh monsters and everything seems to
want to kill her and and the rest of her
crew so she
she needs to you know uh find out what's
going on
solve this mystery how do they end up
here
what does this planet want from them and
you know the story on revolution she
actually learns about the place and
learns about the the
the mystery behind it uh but it's all
about you know like being
stranded on on this uh
kind of scary but also
in a way strangely beautiful world and
facing a lot of nasty nasty creatures
and monsters
yeah so it's like kind of keeping on
that theme of the realm of possibility
and whatnot
how much in the game um has its roots in
the real world and how much is just
playing
crazy sci-fi well it's it's mostly
sci-fi but the themes come from the real
world so
they're they're inspired by the real
world real world
uh you know i think the best stories
come from the real world even if they're
you know about as i said dragons or
fairy tales
and of course spaceships and space
exploration like there is always this
component so on one level scars above
is about reason versus terror
and this is a very important topic to me
and that's a very real world topic
for me like in our world a lot of bad
things come out of fear
and uh this fear you know gives birth to
some
unreasonably dark actions which lead to
more
bad things and more fear and more bad
things and
in a way scars above is like um for me
a metaphor for uh reasons standing up
against terror
you know science against darkness
knowledge against
ignorance so apart from kind of staying
within sci-fi and obviously that kind of
opening up the possibility that this can
actually happen
makes sci-fi what it is is there any
other important reason to you to keep
you know that sense of realism still
there in the game
so there is like yes there there is
there is a reason to keep realism but i
think the better word is to make it
believable
so you know like if you go for absolute
realism you're
kind of limited on you know what what
what you can tell
the story you can tell it's it kind of
is like there is
fiction element to the to the sci-fi
right but
we want to make it believable and the
reason why this is
important is because i would like to
create this what-if
vibe you know i would like it if people
actually ask themselves like what if
this really happened what would i do if
i were suddenly stranded somewhere
on this strange far away from home
world surrounded with
monsters and and terrorists like if you
make this believable
uh people might actually think more
about it so we don't want to go
like super realistic uh but we do want
to make it believable
so that you know because immersion is
really important so that people get
immersed in this world and start
thinking like what would i do if i was
in this in this situation
you know and you know what if this was
really like
what if this happens someday what if an
alien object does
appear near earth someday and what would
happen absolutely and then you mentioned
the lead protagonist kate ward
you told her like you told about her job
title
what else about her you know like who is
she why is she
kate is awesome we love her so kate is a
a very strong and very capable but also
a very caring person you know
so she's an astronaut she's a scientist
a team member a colleague an explorer
and you know she always has like this
uh childlike scientific curiosity you
know
but but one thing she is not and that's
a warrior like a trained warrior she's
not a soldier so she's not like a space
commando or anything
and uh so and she does uh end up in a
situation where like she needs to you
know fight for her life
so that that's a theme that's kind of
like really interesting to us
uh because you know the fact that she's
not a trained
combatant doesn't mean she's not capable
you know
so she has like a strong will a sharp
mind and and she's very brave and tough
but you know like
she's under tremendous stress in our
game and we want to show how
vulnerable she is how scared she is how
distressed
you know because i like true courage uh
doesn't you know it doesn't come out of
lack of fear it comes in face of fear so
we do want to show this fear
and and it's actually like this the fact
that she's overcoming this like fighting
her emotions fighting
you know all the stress that that makes
her courageous and that that's great so
she gets frightened you know she fights
her emotions uh
she's acceptable to panic which i i
think kind of makes her relatable like
she's not like you know
you know i'm all out of gum i'm i'm
kicking ass and chewing bubble gum and
i'm all out of gum you know like that's
that's not her she's she is like you
know she her
heart pounds her voice breaks she
trembles
you know but then and that that's that's
what i really like like
when her voice breaks when she's like
really scared but she like clenches her
fist
and you know the adrenaline kicks in and
she pushes through you know no matter
the obstacle and she does it using
her mind you know and using science and
using her cunning to
you know craft these weapons and and
then gadgets
and and and survive against the odds
awesome so you mentioned
uh that you know kate's a team player
and and that scar
gets sent up who else is in the team who
else are you going to be
um meeting on this adventure so she's
uh she's uh a part of a four-person team
uh there is the the the commander of the
of the mission commander robinson
richard robinson
and he is like uh you know like a a a a
person with a military
background like a pilot and and uh you
know an
officer and like she he is the commander
after all but the rest of the team are
mission specialists you know because
they and this is also kind of like the
idea that uh we
like it's this alien object appears we
send right scientists and explorers
trying to figure
what's going on so so kate is joined uh
by by her uh close friend tamara who is
who is uh and also like a scientist and
an astronaut
and uh and by mike uh a little bit
younger member of the team but who's
also like a communications expert and
like
they're they're they're they're all
scientists working working together to
solve this mystery but kate does get
separated from them and
and you know part of the game is
actually uncovering the fate of her
other team members and you know like uh
i don't want to spoil anything but you
know kate obviously cares
a lot about about uh her her teammates
and her friends
speaking of best feelings that you can
have what are you most proud of
up to date of scars above i'm i'm
actually gonna
give you a corny but very true answer
and i'm most proud of the team
so like making a game is is a huge
effort and it requires a lot of hard
work uh
focus energy dedication but also like
cooperation
communication support so it's just like
looking at a group of people working
together on a common goal that that's
really inspiring and i think that's
truly the case with any development team
like when you ask them like what you're
proud most proud of you know and i i
keep thinking like one
monday in the far future i may actually
forget some of the details during the
development but i will always remember
the people i worked with
that's awesome and then last question
what are the benefits of
signing up with a global publisher like
koch and being
on their brand new uh publishing label
there's a bunch of benefits but like you
know having
access to certain resources due to
experience
uh this is a game you know with many
firsts for us
so having someone to just like you know
share
thoughts and and share the experience is
really valuable
but you know on a personal level i i
have to say this and i'm being perfectly
honest like the biggest benefit for me
uh was meeting a bunch of great people
on your side
and i truly mean this like uh uh it's
it's a continuing pleasure to work with
you uh
not just uh you know not just talking
about the game or how we can make it
better but you know just like we talk a
lot a lot as you know
like we chat about various things just
meeting uh you guys like it's a it's a
tremendous boost
to what we're doing and
you know i don't want to i don't want to
downplay like the obvious benefits
because there's a lot of them like the
you know their infrastructure the
resources but you know
for me personally it's just like meeting
and getting to hang out with you guys
that's
that's really awesome absolutely and
it's a pleasure to hang out with you as
well ivan
and thank you so much for your time i
cannot wait
to let people play skies above because i
know that we have so much fun with it uh
in the office
so thank you very much and yeah we can't
wait to see more
thank you thank you yeah i'm looking
forward to people playing
the game i'm really excited about it and
thank you for this
talk yeah and now for something
completely different
when brian fargo himself the granddaddy
of
top-down isometric rpgs says he is
excited about a game
that's gotta mean prime matter is
getting something right
encased is an isometric dystopian sci-fi
rpg scheduled for release this autumn
and this new trailer which we're
unveiling today
should give you a pretty good flavor of
what the game is all about
it's 1976
and the future has arrived
but here's the skinny we at promise need
you
cronus was formed after a dome-like
structure was discovered five years ago
was it from our ancient past was it made
by aliens
does it run on perfectly harmless
nuclear power
we need to know and humanity is waiting
for you
to help unlock its secrets
descend into the dome itself and join
one of our incredible research teams
the only question is which wing of
cronus is the best fit for you
if you like taking orders cracking heads
ultra violence and guns
lots of guns then the black wing is for
you
can you build and repair incredible
technology but not expect
any credit for it you sound like an
engineer to us
welcome to the blue wing are you a
doctor
scientist mathematician or any other
type of brainiac
we've got you covered in the white wing
do you like taking credit for the hard
work of others but never do
anything yourself those forms won't fill
themselves
that's management mister and the silver
wing awaits
are you a criminal prisoner or have no
discernible skills whatsoever
then you're coming to the orange wing
like it or not
are you ready for adventure are you
ready to make the change with us
are you ready to love it so much that
you'll never want to leave
then join cronus and take the second
giant leap for mankind
under the dome
that's not all opel got to sit down with
the creative brains behind encased
check it out let's go to st petersburg
in russia and speak to vichislav kosahin
creative director of dark crystal games
and the brains behind their
upcoming isometric rpg encased
so slava what is encased
so encased is an old-school rpg
in the sci-fi post-apocalyptic setting
basically awesome so the name encased is
kind of
you know it's a word and and it has
various meanings what's the thinking
behind the name
uh the thinking behind the name comes
from the
actually the setting of the game from
one
main entity of it which is the dome
the games takes place in the anomalous
zone
called the dome which was found
somewhere
in the last unknown desert
on the earth and on our planet and
well basically people who get in there
various scientists technicians
soldiers and adventurers they can't get
back
this is sort of a one-way road so those
guys who explore the the dome they're
encased in there
which i i think makes some sense
in this regard absolutely yes so
um i know that you guys have been
developing this game for for
kind of a long time now how long is it
actually taken to get to the point where
you are
now so we are developing the game
for three and a half years now we
started
late in 2017 with some pre-production
but uh obviously
we have thoughts about a project like
this for years and years before that
before those crystallized in something
you know
something that really exists so it takes
10 years of
thinking behind this game this project
and three and a half years of actual
production time to this to this time to
this point
so considering how long it takes how do
you guys
keep yourself so motivated just on one
like particular title
well we don't we can't say we have any
problems with
motivation or our own because for
most if not everyone on the team this is
the dream
project that uh you know comes to life
so that's that's fine in this regard the
motivation
is always high but also we are in the
early access
and we were really open with the
community from the
very early stages of the project and
because of this openness
and talks with the community and we have
had a crowdfunding and now we are in the
early access
we have this constant feedback on the
project
both positive and sometimes negative
uh which obviously keeps us motive
motivated
if we would be on our own for the for
those like three and a half years and
uh some extra time will uh spend on
developing this game maybe the
motivation could decline a little bit
but with
those constant talks with the community
shared feedback we're all good awesome
and then kind of bringing it back to the
game
given how um development and technology
often is basically dictates how the game
evolves throughout its development
how close to the original concept that
you came up with years and years ago
are you now with the game that you have
currently
the overall concept
we managed to keep it keep it alive
we managed to keep it through it's a
very
very old school crpg type
game which which is inspired by many
golden classics of
late 90s and early 2000s and in that
regard
it all you know all those ideas survived
through the process which is really
great
uh most of the mechanics
abilities perks and all those
little things which these rpgs have
built from we managed to
put it in there too but obviously uh
because technology changed and even you
know
time passes some
less important things i'd say like maybe
graphics or maybe
art style bits or maybe some topics and
themes we
explore those you know transformed and
changed during the process because
making games and
rpgs particular it's an iterative
process and takes many
iterations to figure out what is the
like the heart
what is the idea you want to bring to
the players
so those transformed and crystallized
during this long development but the
original concept the very heart of it
it's all in there which is really great
yeah so speaking about the concept
what's the actual narrative of encased
uh the story of encased it's a story
about exploring this
anomalous zone the dome
the player starts as an employee of this
cronus organization which is the only
organization that controls
entire dome research and studying
there are five departments which are
called wings
a player can start in which affects the
game
a lot and the story of the game this is
the black queen which are the security
and police services
there are white wings which are
scientists
and medics there is the
silver green which are the management
and
you know ruling um win of the of the of
the dome of the cronus
they're uh blue bean which are
technicians and
engineers and there is this special
orange wing
which is contained contains ex-convicts
which were freed to to to go to the dome
to do man various manual labor so you've
mentioned that the game is set in the
early 70s
not only games have been set in that
time period what prompted you to pick
that specific time period well we think
then the 70s is the perfect time for
for for like our game was for what we
are doing
because 70s is like the
last uh tick on the on the timeline of
the humanity
while there were some blind spots
on the on the planet uh first
satellites and first people in space
they
it's all happened in late 50s
and early 60s right
and 70s is
the last uh spot on the timeline
when there are some you know when
satellites
do not have this complete web
surrounding the gay
the earth and the planet and there are
some blind spots
where such an amazing
and dangerous place like dome can be
hidden
and from that that place from that time
the story takes its alternative path
instead of going uh further to the space
humanity
sort of descends into the dome to
to study it and to do those
scientific researches and do those
miraculous
discoveries basically yeah so you
mentioned that this is kind of like a
almost a parallel universe um how far
did you deviate
from what like actually happened in the
70s
compared to what happens in the game i
guess it's seeing as you said that it
devolves it's quite a bit
yeah obviously so the main topic would
be obviously that instead of continuing
the cold war
the west and east if we can call those
they instead start to explore the ideas
of like internationalism and exploring
the dome together and forming that
uh super corporation cronus which is
actually the
uh only foundation that
that exports the dome controls
all the researches and controls the flow
of like artifacts and scientific
researches
which comes from the dome into the
well the rest of the world and yeah
those
uh those ideas are quite different
from what happened in the in the real
world
i i guess and kind of bringing it back
to the real world
almost obviously you guys are based in
russia and life in the 70s was very
different than life was
in the west um how much of that do you
think
translates to to an international
audience once we get out there and how
much do you think
people won't understand because they
just you know no one
kind of really lived over there or no
one really
knew what was happening over there well
as i said i think the game
purchased the ideas of internationalism
when very different
parties across the world could put their
own struggles political and other
struggles aside
to humanity become something
something bigger when it when it's
combined with
everyone is united together
to you know ex to to to ascend
to be something more and to explore the
dome
its dangers and its discoveries
basically
absolutely now bringing it kind of back
to you guys and the developers again
um you you mentioned that you were
inspired by it by other games
what games had like really truly
inspired it not just games but media
and also what do you and the team like
as well when it comes to video games
well we are here all the you know
hardcore rpg
fans so it's not not secret why we
i suppose picked up a project like this
to develop
and it's not a secret that the game
is more it's in a very hard way was
inspired by the fallout series well and
the
other great rpg games of late 90s and
early 2000s and some modern ones too
actually
so speaking about development um what
was the hardest part of making the game
for you guys
i think the easier question would be
what was the easy part i
can't really come with with much things
which were easy
it's it's it's all um
it's an everyday struggle in a way it's
a matter of
fun but it's a it's a happy marathon and
it's a
happy happy everyday struggle basically
for us
absolutely and then moving it into that
more positive thing the happy marathon
what are you most proud of when it comes
to incursed
uh i'm obviously proud of the
both the team and the project itself
because
uh both us here in the team and our
community we often forget that
three and a half years ago there was
nothing there was emptiness
nothing existed and here now
three and a half years later
both with the team effort and the
feedback which we get from the community
there is this great universe a curious
world which is almost ready
to be explored and to be adventured in
inside basically and then moving on to
the last question
what are the benefits of signing up with
a global publisher like
koch media and being on their new label
so we think that signing with the
partner as coach media is really great
because it not only benefits us as
developers
but it uh such partnership also benefits
our community our players we as the
developers
we get more time to work on the project
and polish it so it would be in the
perfect state
while our players will enjoy
more localizations which will make the
game
more accessible to the wider audience
will get the
voice over done which
just make the game better and bring it
on some other
higher level from an isometric
dystopian sci-fi rpg to our next title
which is a fresh
take on the action adventure genre this
team
all the way from iceland specifically
built a mocap studio
for this title and has the incredible
talent
alice hamilton as their lead protagonist
i got to sit down with the guys and ask
them what is this game all about
so echoes at the end is a cinematic
narrative driven action adventure game
uh about ren
uh a person who has trained all her life
to be a warrior in service to a throne
and is now searching and finding her own
identity
uh as she's cast away from the life
she's always known
uh it's a game we wanted to to make all
our lives basically
and for us what we really wanted to
explore was a marriage of
a cinematic experience and
uh the narrative choice driven
storytelling
of rpgs uh finding that
bridge and union is what really inspired
us to go and make our own video game
exactly and and such a big integral part
of the experience
is how you as a player choose to
interact with the characters around you
the different companions the
the characters that you'll run into when
you're going about in the game
and uh trying to solve all the issues
that the player will prepare
that you'll be facing as a player what
was the inspiration behind it
we're at a remarkable point in the game
industry where you know a relatively
small team is able to tackle
such an ambitious vision and it's
actually reasonable
and i think we've just recently arrived
at that point you know there have been
some really
great games making leaps in the past few
years kind of
paving the way for this as the tools and
hardware and software get more
accessible and affordable for smaller
developers
we kind of you know in the early days of
mitch good we came to realize that a
game like this might be possible
and it seemed unreal to us that it might
be at the time
uh but you know growing a team and
building up the attack and pipelines
in-house you know
uh we saw that this was in fact possible
and it's an absolute uh dream for
everyone at the company
to you know be privileged enough to work
on a game like this and to
really shape uh the game that we all
want to make
yeah so kind of sticking on that point
of development and how technology often
drives the direction of how a game
evolves throughout its development
how close to the original concept is the
game now
that's a really good question uh so it's
it's
it's rather close like uh i would say we
didn't really do
any large pivots uh we did make some
changes of course as the vision evolved
and
as we understood better kind of what the
game
was going to be and kind of how we
scoped it to fit a team
uh that would be able to execute on it
but i think
you know we were always uh you know from
day one that the idea for the game kind
of conceptualized we were looking at
the the technology that was allow us to
make this game you know going for
really you know realistic and stunning
visuals you know digital doubles for
characters scant environments
you know you know next-gen uh
development engines
next-gen uh game engines kind of all
those
things were in place for us to make the
game i think the the primary things that
have changed in the making of the game
are more in the details of the execution
of that how we structure the story
uh what kind of game mechanics we want
in a game like that yes and and really
what the identity of our game is and how
we separate that from
other games we genuinely have been
making this game
this game even though it is slightly
different yeah
my work as narrative director has not
had to change a lot exactly we've
mentioned obviously at the start
and throughout what we've spoke about so
far that you guys are based in iceland
and everyone knows the like picturesque
scenery of iceland did you get much
inspiration from your homeland in the
environment
yes absolutely you know iceland is such
a phenomenal
place to live in and it's a beautiful
country that's been featured in you know
many films and videogames before us and
the funny thing is that us growing up in
iceland this is normalcy for us this is
what we've been used to it isn't until
we visit other countries that we realize
that
the rest of the world isn't a fantasy
lot oh my god trees
yes so uh but but yeah i mean it's
absolutely inspired by iceland and you
know i was working as a tour guide for
the longest time and a lot of us like
grew up in the country
from different locations and we pulled
from those locations in the game and
and even for some of them we have nearly
one-to-one replicas of them
you know in the game but the game itself
isn't
based in iceland of course uh we're just
taking inspiration from the more
fantasy level uh vistas and visuals
because while all this is true while we
love iceland and while we'd be fools not
to you
utilize the access we have to icelandic
natural
phenomenons to scan and take references
from
we don't want to make a game about
vikings because
it's something that's been done a lot
and we really want to
make a unique ip that is ours yeah and
that no one has seen before
yeah and we kind of touched on on
characters and and you mentioned the
main character at the very start
tell us about her tell us you know why
what made you choose or why does she
exist the way that she exists
i'll hand that one off to you yeah it's
always a tricky question to answer
without getting into any sort of
spoilers
yeah but uh rin is
as i say she is a character a person
trained from birth to be a weapon
in service to the crown uh i
was really fascinating in exploring the
difference between a person that is
well the juxtaposition between purpose
and independence
and rin is a character burdened by
purpose and chained to it she
is has been given a purpose not of her
own choosing not by her own volition
but one that she has inherent to her
birth and very existence
throughout this game in particular we
want to explore the journey of
going beyond that purpose and going
beyond what
role you are born into and seizing
the the world by the throat basically
uh and i would i would say that she's
born with certain powers that make her
both a pariah
and a uniquely powerful individual
but with that power come certain
challenges and certain
uh superstitions that she's challenged
to overcome
i think that's general enough to avoid
spoilers yeah
i'd like that to do that and you know
just to add the layer to that i think
with the main character she's you know
throughout the game
you're constantly meeting new people
kind of we're setting her in
you know we start with her familiar
setting her kind of role in society and
her kind of what
what's expected of her and we kind of
break free from that throughout the game
as we
meet different characters and and rin
kind of
finds her own path and and purpose like
magnum spoke on
and i think that's really where the
player also steps in and kind of forms
those new relationships
that win forms throughout the game and
really is uh
uh and a factor on those i think
uh you know what really heightens uh rin
as a character in the game is the
performance by the excellent
actress behind her who is aldis amma
hamilton who is
absolutely phenomenal at portraying such
a
such an awesome character what's the
hardest part
of game development so far i know you
guys are still into
in the development but what's been the
most challenging
the most challenging part of game
development ah i think that's a
different answer for every
team yes i think that's a different
answer for every game and i think it
even might be a different answer for
every team member
uh depending on the different uh
perspective that they have into the game
tournament
i think for us you know it's been
vitally important to find the right
people to work on the game
and that's a really difficult thing to
do finding the right people who you
believe in and who
are you know really passionate about
making games like this
and we've been lucky enough to find the
right people so far and we have you know
exceptionally talented people on board
with us making this game
and i think while that is you know often
uh from the outset it's an invisible
part of game development but it's
absolutely essential and
extremely difficult yeah so you kind of
mentioned before
that um you know iceland's quite small
does that mean that you guys kind of
struggle to find
that talent um that's out there or
is it quite rich in terms of game
development so
uh as usual iceland is excellent per
capita
where we're the best at everything per
capita and among those
in this in the nordics we have the most
developers per capita
uh that's not really a useful metric
when you look at the fact that we're
only like 300 thousand people
basically a small fisherman uh fisher
town someplace
uh but you know we iceland is completely
unique in the way that ccp
uh another pretty well known developer
here in iceland kind of paved the way
for all the other gains values here that
are now thriving
uh we have a great educational
infrastructure that you know
pretty much covers all the different
fields of game development here in
iceland
so we have exceptional talent coming out
and so i think
you know considering the size we have
great access to talent
and uh another part of it is that we
have
a lot of icelanders who got into game
development game development early
and moved to other countries and then
moved back with a lot of experience
helping
new teams form and build games here so
while it's definitely a challenge to
find people in a smaller nation we're
blessed by the fact that we do have
exceptional talent here and we have an
educational system that
is actively each year graduating uh
new students who know game development
what halton is saying is that we're a
nation of nerds yes
and like another per capita is that you
know i don't know
it's it's an incredibly high number of
people in iceland who play games at all
ages yep like
an insanely high number yeah that's
really crazy
and you know we've kind of mentioned
what's the most difficult part about
game development but what are you most
proud of up until this point
that's uh yeah it's not it's a difficult
question for answer
because there's so many things i mean
making games is
uh you know you know it takes uh
so many people to do so many things for
it to go correctly and i think what
we're most proud of is that so far we
seem to be doing it correctly
uh with the great people so i think what
we're most proud of
is the team and the progress that we
made with this team
yeah i think that's a very good answer
in general that just
the talent we've collected around us and
the
friendships that have formed so strongly
within this company yeah
i think that's invaluable and is what's
going to
drive it forward and then finally guys
what are the benefits of signing up with
a
global publisher like koch media and
being part of their brand new label
that's a great question uh so obviously
we touched on the part that we're
uh kind of stuck in iceland so our
outreach is quite limited on an island
in the sea
now with all jokes aside the main
benefit is that it's an extension of the
team and it's a great extension of the
team
you know we talk about the things that
have been the most difficult and that's
building the team
and the things that we're most proud of
which is again uh the team that we built
and for us [ __ ] is a fantastic
extension to the team uh you know it's a
publisher full of great people who are
really passionate about games
and they're empowering us to deliver
these games
uh you know worldwide and i think that
is anything uh developer and a business
developer could ask for in a publisher
and we are absolutely glad to have you
guys
thank you so much for your time and i
cannot wait to give people more
information about echoes of the end
from one side of the globe all the way
to the other if you like the game gothic
and hardcore rpgs the last aura crew is
just for you
i got to sit down with two of the guys
from gold knights
and talk all about them and their new
game
hello there guys today i am joined by
gold knight's
creative and game director pavel schnard
an executive producer vladimir gerschall
to talk about their game the last aura
crew
hi ho about so you guys make the last
ora crew what is the game about
it's an action rpg where i try to show
the relativity of good and evil from
different perspective of living and
breathing work
so when you guys say living and
breathing what do you mean exactly
uh it is important to understand that
the last auricus is quite
challenging and skill based rpg but
compared to many other titles in this
genre
our story does not take place in some
dark and deadly realm
waking up in a living and breeding
sci-fi medieval world of wardenia
players find themselves in the middle of
war
for supermancy over the whole planet
there's something
interesting about the war as usual
warriors of each side believe that they
do the right thing
often fighting for survivor and
well-being of their people
so the idea of the game is to show the
player the war
and the euphoria of the winners but also
the misery of the losers
to make the player realize that the
number of decisions he can make in the
game will affect
all the living beings in the world so
you mentioned that you make
choices during the last aura crew how
impactful are they
the impact is major first of all you are
the one who decides which side will win
the war but there are many different
roads throughout
through the game and you can experience
the whole game only after multiple
playthroughs
i want to give the every player his own
experience and try not to push any moral
code of what is wrong and what is right
simply you make the decision and actions
and based on that
individual characters have their own
reactions this creates different
situation
so you can find your own friends and
allies and play the way how you think
it's right or fun
exactly each player can define their own
path
to side with different fictions or
betray them and influence the future
of each race and in the end the entire
planet basically
uh and it is not done uh just by a few
choices
somewhere in in dialogues or by
completing some quests
but you are counted but by your
continuous actions
and decisions let me give you an example
uh in
many scenarios there you are asked to
kill the general african people
and you can obviously refuse doing that
but if you if you decide to kill him
there are many possibilities of what you
can do with his head
which serves as a proof of his debt uh
you can
keep it and become hero or you can give
it to the queen and
come closer to her heart or you can give
it to another characters
of this conflict with with different
outcomes
while i'm playing guys if i decide to be
a little bit mischievous
and kind of go down the route of
everyone hating me
what does that mean for me yes there is
an option that you will try to do as
much harm to do as many beings as
possible
and there are some dark characters that
will be pleased by that however
cooperation with them may be eventually
very painful for you
that's another interesting thing that
often there is some hidden party
involved in many wars which profits from
both sides of the conflict and the
conflict itself
so that's bit of the hidden path in the
game which you can play but
it will be a little bit difficult to
play
so the game has co-op can a friend help
me with the boss battles
can we play the whole entire game
together how does this work
you know those lonely nights when you
play games which are super exciting for
you but you feel a little bit sad that
you cannot share that experience with
anyone that was generally the idea
yeah there is a great demand for couch
play in the whole third person
action rpg genre so we are sure that for
our future audience the
the co-op is going to be one of the most
uh or the key features of our game
and that's why we went even further we
have many situations
what can be solved and cop differently
than in single player
so you can find new fun ways you'll have
to of how to kill some bosses
or solve some puzzles or reach some
special secret areas
but you know at the end of day combat is
bread and butter of an
uh rpg so if you for example play as a
melee tank
while the second player plays a magic
support you will enjoy tons of awesome
hours of shirt fun
oh wait so you're telling me there's
magic and melee
what does this mean for the combat of
the game well the combat is touched at
more experienced players
i'm very much on the way for recent
challenging rpgs that are based on the
skills of the player timing and stamina
we are trying to build some interesting
magic mechanism
in the game that would let you use some
more than block and fast attack buttons
but you know don't forget that our word
has sci-fi roots so
what is for someone magic uh can be for
more developed culture or technology
but be prepared to die i like a lot yeah
a lot
a lot and finally guys i just want to
ask you
what does it mean to be under koch
media's brand new label
honestly it was the best step we could
do in our game development it helped us
dramatically increase the capacity of
our development team and focus primarily
on the game itself
and yet we still have the full creative
control over the game
and all the feedback we are getting is
really helping us to make a better game
so so far it was the best decision ever
yeah i'm very pleased that i could use
my long-standing experience
with big publishing houses and
restructured the game and the team to
shape
which was the right fit for such a
strong partner as a [ __ ] media
from the very beginning of our
cooperation with pablo we were thinking
big
and aiming at building a really
memorable new game franchise
and being part of the starting portfolio
of a brand
new coch media label gives us a great
opportunity to fully achieve it
thank you so much pavel and vladimir for
your time it's been awesome talking
to you about everything the last aura
crew and i just can't wait for people to
get their hands on it
okay bye-bye bye we teased it in the
sizzle and now let's hear from our
friends at starbreeze to talk about
payday 2
payday 3 and their upcoming cooperation
with prime minister
thank you jeff and hi everyone we're
excited to be here
excited to talk about payday and excited
to be working with prime matter
at strawberries we see payday as the
ultimate bankropping experience
inspired by classic heist movies
providing adrenaline-fueled gameplay
where you get to experience the thrill
of being on the wrong side of the law
with a smart plan and a gun in your hand
this
is what we've been doing since the
original game faded the heist
through the sequel payday 2 to the
upcoming
payday 3. and our ever growing player
community
our heisters continue to be an
inspiration for us in everything we do
pushing us to make the best payday
[Music]
possible
the world of payday is an exaggerated
reflection of
reality where order is kept by the long
arm of the law
at least until the heisters turn this
order into chaos giving the law the
middle finger
that's when adrenaline truly kicks in
and the outnumbered gang
keeps beating the odds often escaping
with the cash in a hail
of bullets the payday universe has an
ongoing narrative that has been created
over the years
the gang has built a reputation by going
after the highest profile targets
setting up some of the craziest highest
plans and
going up against some of the most
powerful of enemies and through all of
this
the gang keeps coming out on top in
their exploits the gang has become as
they call it
the tightest crew ever the wider
criminal underworld of payday lives its
own life
where movers and shakers want a piece of
the action or a piece of the payday gang
in the gang's life of crime they are way
past
the point of no return and as we look
ahead for what's to come
the gang will learn that there's no rest
for the wicked
this legacy is something that we
treasure and will build on
expanding on this epic story taking it
all with us
into the future of payday many millions
of players have enjoyed payday so far
it's been an amazing journey for us at
starbase on steam
payday 2 has the biggest player
community of any game
this truly means the world to us payday
turns
10 this year but we're only getting
started
with our team hard at work cooperation
with prime matter
and other partners and above all a
fantastic
player community we are looking to the
future with great anticipation
i'm rich it's payday fellas
the release of pd3 is years away but
we could finish off today with a sneak
peek of what we're working on
a taste of things to come
[Music]
well there you have it quite a lineup
and opal i know we're going to be
hearing much more from prime matter in
the weeks and months ahead right
that's a great question jeff pry mata
will be taking a huge leap into the
streaming world
from june the 14th we'll be streaming
three times a week every
week providing you guys with gameplay
content achievement and trophy hunting
streams
as well as dungeons and dragons in our
own universes
cooking streams and so much more we also
want to get our developers involved
and have it so that you guys get to know
our developers better
not only that but expect to see a lot
more shows from us in the future
and jeff can help us out too absolutely
i cannot wait to see
uh what prime matter has for us in the
future thanks for
announcing with us yesterday at summer
game fest and i look forward to being
back with you again later this summer
no worries jeff and thank you for your
time it's been awesome hosting with you
and i can't wait to do more in the
future
and a thanks to you guys watching to the
streamers who are co-streaming
to our new gamers who are looking
forward to the titles that we've shown
you today
we are focusing on making fun unique and
honest content for you guys
so stay safe stay cool and i will see
you guys on monday
[Music]
bye
you